let's get to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 we are gonna go first to a caller
from the 8th 1/3 area code caller from 8
1 3 tell us who you are and what's on
your mind today 8 & 3 you're on with us
hey I had a kind of a you question to
break it up out of American politics sir
oh okay
you heard about what's going on in
Poland right now they're having a
far-right you know party rise up or now
of course it's called the Law & Order
party yeah of course I have been reading
about that but uh you know of course we
have far-right politics come you're
gonna have neo-nazis come with it I know
they're trying to have like thirty
thousand migrants move there that you
use trying to push that on Poland and I
was thinking about it and I'm thinking
if he U is pushing one of their
countries with migrants when they're
having this far run of rides up I think
that might backfire on them because it
might just you know embolden them more
not to mention your this thirty thousand
migrants you can't just putting them in
harm's way as well I was just wondering
what you thought about that yeah it
becomes difficult in these situations
because on the one hand you don't want
to show that you're changing your policy
because of these extremist elements in a
country but at the same time I think the
argument of putting the the immigrants
themselves in harm's way is a real
concern so I don't know how you handle
it because you also don't if you say hey
you know what because of the uprising of
these anti-immigrant right-wing groups
were no longer going to send these
immigrants to Poland they see it as a
victory and they will become emboldened
to protest even more right they'll say
hey we can prevent immigrants from
coming to our country just by showing up
and demonstrating so I think that's a
real tough one I mean well do you see a
solution to that why I don't mention it
but they're gonna try and for like
economic sanctions on them which I think
it's gonna be like even worse because
they're like oh it gives you that okay
we're just gonna get even stronger and I
mean Jesus Christ the brexit was close
but you want to talk about it Peg's it
or whatever the hell's gonna call yeah
gonna be like 80/20 or something yeah
it's a tough situation but they're in a
rush I think that bottom line my
instinct would be not to give in to the
to the legislative desires or policy
desires of the neo-nazi right-wing
extremist types I would do whatever is
possible not to give in to what it is
that they want yeah it's just Poland
with its history I think it's so much
more difficult to handle whereas you
know the UK is a little different yeah
Hurley really one I told his really not
that long ago about when my dad was in
Poland and some crazy anti-semitic stuff
that he experienced but story for
another day if I will someday retell it
thank you for the call I appreciate it
yeah I thought all right